in this video we'll talk about what
happens when a user decides to activate
a subscription in your app when your app
starts call start connection in the
google play billing library once the
connection is complete you will also
need to call query purchases in order to
handle existing purchases make sure to
override on purchases updated in order
to handle any future purchases that
complete while your app is open once the
connection is properly setup launch the
billing flow in the Google Play billing
library to start the new subscription
purchase after the user completes the
purchase Google Play will send a
purchase token and order ID back to your
app via on purchases updated the
purchase token represents the users
active entitlement to a product or
service your app provides and the order
ID serves as a receipt for the users
transaction with Google before the users
subscription can be activated your app
sends this purchase token to your server
for verification and registration once
your server receives the purchase token
it will first send the token to be
verified by Google through Google Play
Developer API the API call will either
succeed or fail if it fails then the
token is not valid if it succeeds
that means the token is valid and you
should keep track of the information in
the response this purchase information
is then stored on the server and the
server lets the app know that the
subscription is activated
you can now grant the user the
appropriate access to your product or
services for more information visit the
link on screen or check out our other
videos here